good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carlson tonight imagine being a
historian a hundred years now trying to
figure out what happened here
there are a lot of questions they're
going to puzzle you but one of the most
baffling will be how did Joe Biden get
the Democratic nomination in 2020
was the year you will remember when we
learned that white people are bad and
systemic racism is responsible for
everything that has gone wrong in the
world
and yet 2020 was also the year the
Democrats nominated by their free choice
an elderly white man from a slave state
who'd once eulogized a clan recruiter
so the anti-white party picked the white
guy
how did that happen well it's pretty
simple Democrats care about power and
power derives from winning when you lose
you don't have power
and Bernie Sanders couldn't win Sanders
terrified the donor class so Democrats
went with Joe Biden who loves the donor
class and is loved by them and from a
fundraising perspective that turned out
to be a wise choice by the end of that
cycle Democrats had spent a total of 8.4
billion dollars that includes 400
million just from Mark Zuckerberg and
that total does not even include the
tens of billions in free media coverage
as slick and dishonest as any paid ad
but that unlike paid ads is not
regulated by campaign Finance law
so if you add all of that up the
Democratic party dropped more in that
presidential year than the entire annual
GDP of most African countries all to
dislodge Donald Trump from the White
House nothing like that has ever
happened
can they do it again that's the question
before us and it's a tougher question
this round two and a half years ago many
voters could tell themselves that Joe
Biden might unite the country some
mistook his dementia for moderation
but no one can make that mistake now
with the American economy in decline in
the rest of the world in obvious chaos
Biden's going to have to come up with a
whole new set of lies in order to keep
his job and that's not an easy thing
and that may explain why as of mid-april
2023 where we are now Joe Biden still
has not formally announced his
re-election campaign
he was asked about it this morning on
NBC here he is sounding less than all in
are you saying that uh that you would be
taking part in our upcoming election
you know being the the you know the guy
who's pushed him out come on help a
brother out
I plan on running now but we're not
prepared to announce it yet
he can barely speak the words we're not
prepared to announce it yet he says if
his eyes closed well why aren't they
announcing it well you know why he's
going to be 82 by the next inauguration
and no one really other than his wife
thinks that's a good idea because it's
not
so where does that leave Democrats well
if you're a rational person who took
them at their word you would assume the
party the Democratic party would replace
Joe Biden with someone who embodies
their highest values you imagine a trans
black woman with a background in
corporate HR or a latinx drag queen with
purple hair and lots of face piercings
or maybe even Kamala Harris
but no in fact no chance that would be
principled and therefore they will never
do it nominating someone you say you
support no
when Biden leaves or more likely to
shoved aside they're going to nominate
another straight white man who loves the
big Banks
someone even oilier and Faker than Joe
Biden
why would they do that because it worked
last time and we're guessing if we head
to bet tonight it's going to be Gavin
Newsom
we can't say that for certain but we
have noticed Gavin Newsom was at the
White House not long ago when Joe Biden
wasn't just kind of measuring the
curtains and then over the weekend we
saw this Gavin Newsom sitting down with
the Democratic party's former
spokeswoman now in Residence at MSNBC
Jen pasaki
pasaki didn't conduct really an
interview she's not a journalist
she gave Newsome instead a chance to
outline his platform for when he takes
complete control
so don't dismiss him you may be in the
habit of dismissing Gavin Newsom pay
close attention as he gives his pitch on
MSNBC
you know I just finished 18 events in
five days in California I've sacrificed
my heart and soul for my state and I
take a backseat to no one on that so I
get it but I also don't get what's going
on in this country I don't get why
everybody's not doing what we're doing
all the progress the last half century
is being rolled back in these states in
real time in just the last few years I
don't think people fully understand the
rights regression individual liberties
on civil rights on voting rights on the
gerrymandering that's happening out here
yeah
I mean is your brain exploding if you're
a literal person maybe so this is the
guy who forced every one of his 40
million residents in his state to get an
experimental vaccine whether they wanted
to or not
lecturing you about individual rights
and civil liberties quote I don't get
why everyone isn't doing what we're
doing in California he says maybe
because it's not working because the
people who live in your state who can
afford to leave have more people have
left California this year than any state
in the country California the largest
net immigration in the United States
they actually ran out of U-Hauls it was
that bad so you have a mixture of
billionaires and desperately poor people
who are dependent upon the state
kind of like Latin America that's
exactly the economic structure
increasingly of the State of California
it's not a place of promise and you know
that because middle class people with
families aren't moving there
that's how you know is your state doing
the right thing well people who haven't
made it but would like to
would be moving there not fleeing from
tearing in other countries or desperate
poverty in Central America but from
other parts of America are they moving
there no they're not where are they
going
well actually they're going to Florida
that's not a political point it's just
true and it's measurable so you'd think
if you were a normal person and you're
running California you'd think what are
they doing in Florida that we should be
doing no not Gavin Newsom and this is
the key to his appeal
to democratic leaders like Joe Biden he
will literally say anything and then
he'll take it to 11 and lecture the
person who's doing a better job than he
is on how he's a bad person
watch Newsom tell the governor of
Florida how to run a state
there was a pretty startling split
screen you had a thousand kids in
Nashville out there protesting the lack
of action on gun reform measures well
you had Governor DeSantis signing a bill
on permanentless carry behind closed
doors
scared to death who is he scared of
scared of the people scared of the
people in Florida yeah that
overwhelmingly opposed that position but
I think the majority of NRA members you
know probably oppose that position
this is what happens with everything
about you from your physical features to
your very Soul has been altered by
cosmetic surgery just like Joe Biden but
younger you'll say literally anything
words have no connection to reality
there's no expectation that you're
describing something real
you're merely using words as a tool to
gain power that's terrifying it's
dishonest to its core so you just heard
Gavin Newsom say that only leaders who
are quote scared of the people let the
people carry firearms
they're so scared of the people they let
them defend themselves by contrast when
you're a completely legitimate leader
presiding over a system that's not
rigged
you start confiscating guns you live in
a state where only the governor's
bodyguards can be armed
it's like what you're seeing here is not
just the Triumph of packaging over
reality
but the Triumph of dishonesty over truth
that's so dishonest that he's not even
trying to convince you
he's trying to reshape reality Itself by
the way why wouldn't he if men can
become women
then why wouldn't everything Gavin
Newsom says be true just because he said
it
so what's the effect on the actual State
our largest state the prettiest State
what was for decades the economic engine
of the United States California what has
been the effect of Gavin newsom's
leadership on that state well this has
been well chronicled newsman's been the
governor of California beat a recall
recently since 2019 for four years
before that
he ran San Francisco where he's from so
how's San Francisco doing under good
leadership San Francisco would be
thriving
but under Gavin newson's leadership well
here's what's happening in San Francisco
friends identify the victim as Don
carmignani a former San Francisco Fire
commissioner he suffered a fractured
skull broken jaw and lots of lacerations
to his face and head carmignani showed
up to his mother's place after they
refused to move soon they picked up and
put down near the corner laundromat
carmignani confronted them and that they
say is what provoked the brutal beating
the crime angering and traumatizing
those who heard or saw it all unfold so
I moved here because I loved the city
and it's becoming more and more
disturbing to live to live here
yeah they just closed today actually a
Whole Foods in downtown San Francisco
not a mom and pop place a Whole Foods
a well-backed in fact owned by Amazon
company biggest company in the world
owns the grocery store and they still
had to close it
a grocery store that caters to rich
people and one of the richest cities in
the world and they had to close it
because why because the people who
worked there were too afraid for their
own physical safety to show up for work
so that's what's happening in San
Francisco by the way last week Bob Lee
the founder of Cash app was murdered
stabbed to death on the street and what
they tell us is one of the nicest parts
of San Francisco
and then apparently according to
surveillance video the guy who murdered
him randomly just murdered him on
principle I guess walked down the street
completely at ease pulling a rolling bag
behind him because he has nothing to
fear because there are no cops
this is a state in which crime has been
legalized and the only crimes are now
thought crimes if you disagree with the
people in charge then you're in serious
trouble but if you hurt others or steal
you're fine you're part of a protected
class that's the definition of tyranny
and there are still some people in
California who understand that here's
one sheriff in Riverside County
in the last 10 years criminals have
become
increasingly more violent and Brazen
what we are seeing in in response to
these very LAX laws on on crime the the
the push to decriminalize everything the
push to lessen the penalty for something
or even take away the penalty for crime
is basically emboldening criminals to do
more it's really horrifying for law
enforcement and it is horrifying for the
public that has to do with it
so here's our guess we don't know the
guy but we would bet money that the
second that man is vested in this
pension in other words the second he can
leave he'll be in Idaho for Arizona
or anywhere other than that state
because you can't live in a state like
that unless you're rich of course
so if you cared about the state of
California
you would do something about this
but Gavin Newsom has completely ignored
the condition of his State physically
it's now filthy or the lives of the
people who live there instead he's doing
what they all do which is doubling down
on identity politics
pandering to people on the basis of
their skin color or their sexual
orientation or whatever and because
ultimately he is a stiff robotic lizard
man he's doing in the most awkward
possible way here he is April 5th at the
new College of Florida because he is
running for president
trying his best to seem interested as he
collaps along to an ethnic song and
dance
let me
so you want to know if he's running for
president well he flew to Florida to
degrade himself on camera and
self-abasement is the number one
requirement of politics you have to be
willing to leave your dignity at the
door and for Gavin Newsom that's easy
so
if your first reaction to that is to
recoil in revulsion and turn off your
television set then you're the threat to
democracy normal people are the threat
to democracy Newsome's campaign ad and
this is the first of his presidential
campaign as we predict makes that
perfectly clear watch
we can't solve a problem without first
identifying it the problem in our
country right now authoritarian leaders
who are so hell-bent on gaining power
and keeping it by whatever means
necessary that they're directly
attacking our freedoms in state after
State that's why I'm launching the
campaign for democracy we're going on
the road to take the fight to states
where freedom is most under attack where
Republican leaders ban books criminalize
doctors fired teachers intimidate
Librarians kidnap migrants Target trans
kids still gracism condone anti-Semitism
Force the victims of rape and incest to
carry their attacker's baby where they
ignore the will of the people they make
it harder to vote and easier to buy
assault weapons will help lead the fight
to make sure we elect leaders in 2024
who believe in democracy
oh the huevos on that man you got to
give him credit everything in that ad is
not only untrue it is the mirror image
of the truth it is the exact opposite of
the truth and it's therefore not just
misleading it is evil this is not a
question of we disagree on something
this is a fact of someone flipping
around the truth and inverting it
if you're opposed to men in dresses
twerking in front of kids you're
intimidating Librarians if you pause
before you say castrate children you're
targeting trans kids and of course if
you're not with his program you don't
believe in democracy or promoting
authoritarianism this is the man who's
governor of a state in which there
really is no democracy in which all the
candidates and the election outcomes are
chosen by the unions which are in bed
with the Democratic party is a one-party
state
and the man who presides you over a
one-party state is lecturing you about
democracy
right
this is the guy who shut down the state
of California and all of its schools for
all the poor people while he sent his
children to in-person private schools
and went to dinner at the most expensive
restaurant in the United States
meanwhile anyone who didn't get his
creepy shot he compared to a criminal to
a criminal to a drunk driver watch
and with all due respect
you don't have the choice
to go out and drink and drive and put
everybody else's lives at risk that's
the equivalent
of this moment with the deadliness and
efficiency of the Delta virus
so that turned out to be completely
untrue completely provably untrue as a
matter of Science and again the literal
Among Us are Driven Crazy
by watching a videotape like that but
Gavin Newsom is not Driven Crazy doesn't
bother him at all he's never apologized
he's never revised what he said before
he just kept going this is a man who
will say anything
and people who will say anything tend to
be willing to do anything
and like Joe Biden he has consistently
run as a moderate and falsely back in
as mayor of San Francisco he promised to
eliminate homelessness within the city
within 10 years that of course didn't
work out he's never apologized for that
in fact homelessness has grown by double
digits
under his stewardship of the state but
if you want to understand who Gavin
Newsom really is if you want to
appreciate not just the dishonesty but
the Deep malice at the core of him the
desire to hurt other people and the
indifference to human suffering that has
been the Hallmark of his governorship
watch this clip from 2020 on sobriety
clean and silver is one of the biggest
damn mistakes this country's ever made I
know it's a Hold Your Hand idealistic
point of view that somehow magically I
mean God bless some of you if you're
like me I've been known to have a glass
of wine at night watching some of the
Nightly News uh we all need to
self-medicate periodically
we all need to self-medicate
periodically well now we have a country
in which virtually everyone is
self-medicating all the time very often
with the help of doctors and nowhere is
it worse than the state of California if
you cared about the people who lived in
the state of California you would notice
this nearly 30 000 Californians die
every single year from drugs and alcohol
that's the most of any state
to put in perspective that is close to
10 times as many people who die every
year from gunfire
and of course addiction is the central
driver of homelessness
which has not only made the state ugly
and dangerous and unlivable
but has also destroyed the lives of the
people who are living on the streets
what about them Gavin Newsom doesn't
care quote clean and sober is one of the
biggest damn mistakes this country ever
made really
if you're willing to say that if you
care so little about the people who live
in your state that you will mock their
sobriety
then you're definitely running for
president
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from Tucker Carlson
tonight